yeah welcome to this video playing Grand
Master krupa again always great I like
to play against those strong GM's is
really a good player you can really see
it the games okay yeah this is
interesting this is some quite an
interesting line yeah I studied this a
while back for for black but i discarded
this because of exactly what I'm playing
now but I have forgotten some details
special be three I really forgot it I'm
five I thank you five the promise he
loses quite some time with the Queen and
it's not so clear that at the end his
pieces on good squares night on g4 Queen
on c6 this also tempo gayness like
Bishop b5 this should be five yeah maybe
Queenie forum
y is h 3 a good move just h 3 i've got
Queenie to it the only cannot sacrifice
or anything but do I really need to do
this can also just develop him why not
yeah got a good development shouldn't
shouldn't be bad this position Wow dad
looks like we should be for some action
that's let's castle first and rookie one
I really have strong strong doubts about
what is playing in there should be for
Bishop before it smooth
yeah this should be four it's not fatal
but it looks it looks rather annoying
it's not winning material or or anything
but you keep asking yourself what is the
light doing on G form for example that
is some prophylactically moving the
Queen away and allowing 96 problem so is
there some interesting way to to improve
the position maybe Queen d2 l4 or
something like that don't know what you
can take f3 don't want that ok let's
let's kick the night away first and now
decide how to continue
oh come on let's do some preparation
goes yeah f I thought better wait for
this he takes d4 knows he takes the most
my Center strengthened and otherwise I'm
threatening Bishop e3 basically yeah not
a winning the night but he would then be
forced to play Knight f5 within our
Bishop always doing this he's allowing
this just just like that
should be three night takes should take
special age 6 yeah yeah I can do that I
want to play Bishop h6 of course getting
rid of this this bishop
of course I must be a conscious if I
exchange the bishop and he gets the G
file then the bishop on b7 and yeah rook
on GA term can be quite a problem
ok let's try to attack a fight first
then how does he protected yes but I
thought at the end i have i have 54 now
isn't this good
I thought this would be a would be good
for wide
yeah the ships are stronger than nights
you'll see it time and time again Quincy
6 coming I have f4 f4 is so much better
therefore man alive rookie to to to
protect on g2 if I need to
check-check
no I can take yeah Oh Pooh Oh what the
heck FC led f6 Wow ok at least I don't
have much choice I'm if I'm not mated
yet so it's just luck not mated
instantly at least
kaveh some squares here maybe it was
relatively a good place for the king oh
now it's got d5 crap just crap be 3d
five yeah I know rook g1 rookie aid or
something yeah Queen edge one meet
cannot prevent that they don't think so
or queen of three don't know why ah what
the heck yeah and completely a
completely overlooked I was I was so
sure that you play rook g7 but then i
can really safely take a six this is
stronger um this was stupid okay but I'm
probably a bad anyway the the bishop is
just so strong when Bishop d7 compared
to the night I probably made some
mistake around here
here somewhere here I didn't really what
I didn't appreciate is this weakness of
the pawn and here here here Queen g5 is
very strong for example i only saw later
that this pawn is 3 problem i can't just
attack it this is a terrible position
for like the computers just on 0.8 but
this is close too close to curtains
actually what what does he do know this
this makes my night so strong the
computer gives this a slightly better
for white but just this is nonsense why
this why does excellent here should win
this is far far too strong ah yeah but I
only later saw that the pond is real
problem here was was intending bishop
age 6 which is not so bad an idea but I
hear the problem is if I do this now it
just goes whoop g8 and then has got play
on the G file as well one tongue yeah
this is strong I thought this would be
I'm still still okay Mike Allen I can do
they can do that but it's just the
difference between those two pieces the
night would need a couple of moves as
the night would be here or something
that it's a completely different story
but it's on a three hmm yeah yeah nice
game you played this plate this nicely I
had this shot with Queen g5 but some
interesting game yeah thanks for
watching